hello darlings happy valentine's day it
is i michael knowles the daily wires
love guru
the producers have been perusing reddit
the deep bowels of the internet
for the myriad romantic dilemmas that
people are facing today so that i can
pontificate and give you my expert
advice i call him
the love guru we have
five files here
five very difficult
thorny romantic cases
huh
we will be going through them one by one
without further ado let's get started on
case
number
one she canceled our date
because of my zodiac sign
well you know actually on second thought
here's the advice
according to
the people of it astrology is just
racism for women
true
uh she's obviously cancer oh
come on that's pretty funny uh that's
such a virgo thing to do you're telling
me
uh well i mean you are an aries
all right let's see this guy's full
issue i'm a bit thrown off by this but i
was canceled on due to my zodiac sign
throughout the week before work i visit
a coffee shop i go practically every
weekday and i've been seeing the same
barista there every morning we seemed to
click well with our small conversations
and after chatting with her for a few
weeks i decided to offer my number since
she was on the clock
she declined to take my number but gave
me her snapchat
okay
we chatted a bit on snapchat and agreed
to go on a date friday about an hour
after that she said she wouldn't be able
to go out with me because she saw on my
snap profile that i was in aries she
said she doesn't date aries but it was
nice meeting me is this something that
is common in the dating world i've never
been rejected over my zodiac sign
before so it kind of surprised me okay i
have a few different layers of advice
here
first of all
if a woman
is making these big sorts of decisions
potentially life-changing decisions
based on astrology
run
not merely because she's very probably
an idiot but also because she might be a
witch we'll find the witch may we burn
uh see the issue with astrology in the
bible when they say don't you know
consult astrologers and things is not
because astrologers are charlatans
although very often they are charlatans
but also because astrology is obviously
real and can compromise your free will
so don't do that you know so sometimes
it's real engine so you don't want to do
that that's a very very bad thing she
sounds a little bit kooky so probably
that would give you a pretty terrible
life and then the i'd say the deepest
layer of advice here is it might just be
an excuse because she doesn't like you
that much after you chatted so i hate to
give you the really hard advice here but
it's probably just an excuse like oh no
i'm i'm busy i've got yeah i've got to
study for an exam oh yeah my grandma
died oh my other grandma died oh my
third grandma died
it's not you it's me i don't think that
works so it's okay buddy there's more
fish in the sea number two pretty sure
this girl i'm seeing has an only fans oh
uh how do i find the evidence
uh you go to onlyfans.com is that easy
uh the first response is don't push your
misogynistic white male bs on her if you
can't handle it leave no need to try to
prevent her from living her best life
yeah if you don't love me when i'm a
prostitute you can't have me when i
remain a prostitute because i refuse to
give it up for a better life um no no
that's not great advice tiny hands 25
says i guess it just really depends on
how hot she is
a kid is already tough but maybe she's
enough of a smoke show to get over that
and only fans i guess maybe she's a
child too and she could be making bank
so that that advice is not only do you
need to respect the only fans thing but
hey you can also make some money on it
[Music]
you can be a pimp you can be what you
always wanted to be a pimp okay
what's the full problem here my friend
let's not get into the ins and outs of
why i think this girl hasn't only fans
all right calm down here with the
graphic descriptions
she has kids and she financially carries
them
and her legit universally unattractive
female friend who babysits for her
she does side hustles some that i know
about and she doesn't live like a super
boss high roller but to me there's no
way her life adds up she says she
doesn't get help from baby daddies or
family she seemed from the start to have
suspiciously really good game at sending
me captioned spicy photos over the phone
that i didn't request or instigate
there are a few other reasons but i will
not get into them since they are a bit
more personal in nature i'm 90 sure she
has this going on she claims that she's
not doing it and has never done anything
like that i don't believe her the bottom
line is my position is as a man with
resources i'm doing what i'm doing
anyway because i have to do to do my due
diligence it's not a choice it's really
more about moral due diligence i can't
seriously be with a person who would do
something like that and lie about it to
me if she wants to involve me in her
life she already has strikes against her
and it's amazing i'm still seeing her
knowing she already has kids and
everything
i'm starting to like the girl a lot more
than i like you i think you're
you might be the baddie here guy if this
is your attitude uh how do i find out
that she has an only fans how do i
discover it we've already had
conversations where she knows a
surprising amount of information about
how that works for girls she knows about
geoblocking how do i find the evidence i
think i can handle it if i just 100 have
the evidence you sound like a freaking
psycho this woman should run from you as
fast as she possibly can there should be
uh this woman-shaped hole in the door
she runs so fast out of the room because
you're pursuing her how charitable that
you would even entertain the possibility
of having a relationship with her even
though she's already got all those
strikes against her you know like kids
she didn't even make the responsible
choice and kill her child when she got
knocked up gosh can you you're like
mother teresa aren't you buddy good
grief i don't maybe she hasn't only fans
maybe not you obviously you can't trust
her that's more a you problem than her
problem
you're like calling in the nsa and the
fbi to figure out the details of this
woman's past life good go
seek help see go get a you don't need a
girlfriend you need a therapist go find
a therapist
all right next question number three
i saw my friend's fiance on a dating app
i haven't talked to him in a few years
should i say something to him
oh the current fiance yikes this is the
the answers from people on reddit why
assume that the fiance is cheating on
him rather
they could be open or polyamorous
and telling him would just shame their
fun and open lifestyle
just mind your business and don't force
your radical and close-minded opinion on
him that marriage has a meaning you know
your radical insane opinion
that you shouldn't just be a hedonistic
sexual degenerate you know that crazy
view
next one
i want to read the name for this second
respondent tilikum was framed
that was the uh sea world killer whale
that that killed that lady great name uh
send him an anonymous email fair enough
champagne or boy the correct thing is to
match her and i'm not gonna read that
word
but
it's uh naughty and no you should not do
that to her uh none of your business
your friend will never believe you
been there done that
that might be true as well all right
let's get the whole story hi all i was
swiping through bumble last night and i
was surprised to see my friend's fiancee
pop up on my screen she was verified
through the app so i don't think it was
a bot her post didn't mention anything
about her being in an open relationship
or anything like that i just remember my
friend posting something on social media
about her like a week ago about how
lucky he is to have her and how much she
means to him so it kind of threw me for
a loop i checked and the post is still
there and his profile pic is of him and
her his relationship status says they
are engaged they also have a young child
together oh my gosh
the thing is that i'm not close with him
anymore we went to high school together
and then worked for a few years together
at the same job we got along pretty well
and hung out outside of work but stopped
talking over time i checked my messages
and the last time i talked to him
directly was over two years ago we'll
interact on each other's social media
posts every once in a while but that's
about it my question is should i bring
this to his attention i feel some
obligation since we used to be friends
but at the same time we haven't talked
in a while so maybe it's not my place
what is the correct thing to do here
i the thing is i don't know how dating
apps work
because i
got together i got back together with my
now wife like right as dating apps were
coming out you've got mail so it was i
just i missed it so i don't and the
reason i mention this is
is it possible that this chick is
just still is on the dating apps but
she's not actively using it
so what did she sign up for it six
months ago and just she's so people are
still seeing her
and
it's it's but she's not really actively
doing it i don't know i you know if you
could figure that out that would be
helpful because if she is still
prowling about even though she's
allegedly engaged to this guy
i would
i would tell him i know the impulse here
is don't get involved don't you know
it's easier to just ignore it but if
this person is in any way still your
friend i do think you probably owe it to
him to just you you don't need to make
any accusations you don't need to you
don't need to really involve yourself
and
swipe her you know and then go on a date
and be like hey lady stop screwing
around on my friend
but you could just
maybe shoot him a note or a text or
whatever and say
hey bro uh this is going to seem kind of
weird i don't want to butt my nose in
where it doesn't belong
i'm sure it's just some glitch on the
website or something but
i saw your i was swiping and i saw your
fiance on this thing i just wanted to
give you a heads up no problem the thing
is if as one of the commenters said if
your
friend or former friend reacts in a
really negative way doesn't matter
because you guys aren't that close
anymore uh but i i do think it is the
right thing to do so i i would do it i
would i would let him know i think you'd
feel bad if
i mean i guess i was gonna say if they
got married and had kids and but i guess
they already have a kid together which
is
even more craziness to this whole
scenario
but i do think you'd feel worse if they
you know years and years later he finds
out this chickie has been sleeping
around the entire time and it's just a
complete betrayal
of their entire married life
so i would do it i'd bite the bullet and
do it worst case you lose a friend that
you don't see that much anymore we'll
get to more saucy scintillating advice
in just one second first though you know
that inflation
is going through the roof it's cleaning
out your pockets with really bad policy
geared against the middle class which is
why it has never been more important to
rethink how we shop and choose brands
that are effective safe and in it for
the long haul our partner naturally it's
clean can help naturally it's clean is
dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing your cost reducing
your waste and reducing other harmful
chemicals in your home their safer
chemistry solutions use nature's
powerful plant-based enzymes to clean
areas of your home such as the bathroom
the floors and the kitchen they don't
just push the muck around they use those
enzymes to break it down now you might
be saying michael how can this help you
fight inflation well because they not
only sell ready-to-use bottles but they
also offer many of their top cleaning
solutions in cost-saving concentrate
options a lot of their concentrate
solutions will yield 12 bottles driving
down the cost per bottle saving you big
money head on over right now to
naturallyitsclean.com
get the daily wire essential kit
stocked with four great products for
fifteen percent off just go to naturally
it's clean dot com slash michael mich
ael use promo code michael to save an
additional 15 off your order do not
delay
get this break from bite inflation try
out these great cleaning products
naturally it's clean.com
michael next up number four
he made me go half on the first date
any reason is a good reason not to
continue dating if you're not interested
says one person another person all
details aside seeing a total of 115
dollars being spent on a first date is
sickening
because it's that's far too little to
impress a woman i don't know okay always
offer to pay half and always refuse to
pay more than half stick to this at all
costs works for any gender
no what are you like
what what are you uh
are there a lot of words i want to use
right now that are not family friendly
are you a girly man what do you mean
always just every look every gender just
needs to pay half of you should never
hold the door for a woman and you should
do that so i'm i'm a male feminist yeah
okay bro
prob is a hot take
but i find that a valid reason to no
longer want to pursue something i
believe whoever initiated the date
should pay letting you split the whole
thing if offered wouldn't be a turn off
to me but splitting way unevenly
is your argument is euphemism for buy
things for me yeah sort of because men
and women are different okay let's see
the
full post i 24 year old female met this
guy on hinge 32 year old male and he
invited me out to dinner oh okay he
chose the time and place we made it
there and it was a 30 minute wait so he
suggested getting a drink at a bar
across the street we ended up getting
our appetizer there too since the wait
was a bit long i offered to pay for the
drinks didn't think he would let me but
he said it's okay i could pay for the
next dinner i guess
the drinks and appetizer was 45 bucks he
paid we made it to dinner and it rounded
up to about 70 i paid oh my gosh this is
extremely unattractive to me only
because it was a first date he knew he
would get me to pay for dinner and
ordered more appetizers and lots of
extras he chose the place and initiated
the date oh my gosh but i ended up
paying outside of this the conversation
was okay honestly the monetary portion
of the date threw me off it was pretty
gross to me i've never had that happen
he texted me but i haven't texted back i
think i'm no longer interested this is a
good reason to cut him off yes it is it
absolutely is i'm not totally opposed to
splitting checks especially now people
go on like a thousand dates every day
because of all the dating apps and you
can especially if you're in a big city
just always you're swiping right
so
i'm not in all cases 100 opposed to
splitting the check i would never do it
i mean i find it personally kind of
repugnant but i understand why some
people do it now especially if they're
much younger especially if they don't
have you know any kind of savings or
anything but in oh my gosh to have the
woman
pay for dinner you invite the woman out
you pick the place and then you have the
woman pay for more than half of the bill
that is so
so lame oh my gosh just as a rule this
is a rule in all of life if you invite
someone to dinner
and especially if you pick the place but
just in general if you invite someone to
dinner you are expected to pick up the
bill
now the other person might say here
let's split it let's and maybe you know
you can do that little dance and then
you split it oh okay fine but it is
man woman child anyone you're you happen
to be having a meal with if you invite
them out it is expected that you will
pay for it
when did people people don't learn
manners anymore well the
you get the last laugh i guess because
this jerk doesn't end up getting a nice
nice girlfriend so haha too bad for him
okay
last relationship problem and then i've
got to listen i've got other patients
that i've got to see i can't just deal
with reddit all day
he said i have potential
if i lost weight
okay
all right so
the responses it's code for i will sleep
with you but as soon as i find someone
else i'm gone
you know what will make you perfect
losing the 175 pounds of the this rude
jerk of a guy
says someone else if a man applied this
logic he'd be forever alone sure but men
and women are different so whatever a
girl canceled a date after my confession
that i'm not exactly six feet tall i'm
five eleven oh yeah well it's like you
know anyone who says i'm six feet tall
is five eleven because if you're six
feet tall you say you're a six one
uh okay let's see the full story i a 23
year old female had a third date with
this guy a 23 year old guy everything
was fine until he mentioned that he
already finds me cute but i would be
perfect if i lost weight
oh my gosh
i've always been upfront about the fact
that i'm on the larger side i'm
175 centimeters and weigh 80 kilograms
and are apparently french or something
why are you using those silly liberal
measurements whatever i don't know 80 i
don't know what i don't know what that
is i'm an american speak american damn
it so it's not like it was a surprise
for him before we met i asked him why
are we even here then he said that he
would find it stupid to stop himself
from dating me which i personally think
that's weird because it's clearly an
important thing for him my self-esteem
isn't at its highest to begin with so
this definitely isn't helping either so
okay the producers tell me that's 170
pounds okay so you know a little bit on
the larger side but you're the guy
whatever i mean people come in all
shapes and sizes that's fine and the guy
is saying i think you're attractive but
but you're not exactly perfect for how i
want you now so you know figure it out
and then then we can be together yeah
you should run screaming from this guy
because it's it's not merely that the
guy
finds thinner women more attractive that
that's not even the problem the problem
is that he thinks that you're a little
love affair i don't even i don't really
like the word relationship it's so
clinical and modern and lame and
millennial world of relationship we're
in a partnership so you sound like
you're in an accounting firm or
something
so in your your love affair what what
he's making the whole thing about is his
tastes
his
fantasies his his
idea and his idol of what
his
beloved will be and so what he's saying
is you almost kind of fit into that so
i'm going to try to squeeze pardon my
imagery here i'm going to try to squeeze
it and make it all fit into this box
that i've created of of the person i
want to be in love with and you'll sort
of do for now you're almost there but
that's not really love right he's not in
love with you or it doesn't really seem
to have any care for you at all he loves
this he has an infatuation he has has a
love of this this image he has concocted
for himself and he's going to try to
superimpose that image over you or vice
versa
but he sounds like just a big loser
this guy who says for you to lose weight
he's a big loser if you ask me and you
should uh run run away from him okay
that's the i guess a lot of the modern
dating advice with these schmucky
dude this was this was the schmucky dude
episode i'm sure there are crazy women
out there too right into these things
but this seems to be the shmucky dude
episode a lot of shmucky dudes around
and ladies you should flee i'm michael
knowles the love guru the love doctor
here at the daily wire we will see you
next valentine's day
[Music]
[Music]